YESTERDAY I THINK CHRIS WAS
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT DAY YET
IN SOMETHING IS ONLY BEEN
AROUND FOR THREE WEEKS AND
ONE DAY IT WAS THREE WEEKS
AND ONE DAY IT WAS THREE
WEEKS AGO LAST NIGHT THAT WE
FIRST BECAME AWARE THAT THERE
WAS ANY CONTROVERSY INVOLVING
DESHAUN WATSON YESTERDAY A
PRESS CONFERENCE WAS HELD BY
TONY BUSBY AND I'VE HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY HE'S
ABOUT HIM AND I'VE HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS HE SAID THEY'RE
DISINGENUOUS. BUT WHAT HE DID
YESTERDAY IS WHAT HE SHOULD
HAVE DONE ALL ALONG NOW, IT
TOOK SOME TIME TO GET ONE OF
THE ALLEGED VICTIMS TO THE
POINT WHERE SHE WAS
COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD
AND SPEAKING BUT IT SHOULDN'T
BE ABOUT THE LAWYERS. IT
SHOULD BE ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS AND
TODAY CHRIS IT BECAME ABOUT
THE INDIVIDUALS. WE KNOW OF
TWO NAMES OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUED DESHAUN WATSON ONE OF
THEM ACTUALLY SPOKE AT THE
PRESS CONFERENCE YESTERDAY
AND IT CHANGED EVERYTHING
HAVING A NAME A FACE AND A
VOICE CHANGES EVERYTHING FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WITNESSING THESE
EVENTS PLAY OUT, RIGHT IT
DOES IT HITS HOME OR YOU KNOW,
YEAH, YOU GOT A NAME A FACE,
YOU KNOW, YOU SEE THE
EMOTIONS IT KIND OF HITS HOME
TO THE FACT OF LIFE.
LIKE, YOU KNOW THE DAMAGE
THAT COULD BE DONE TO THESE
PEOPLE AND THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
ISSUES OR WHATEVER. I MEAN,
YEAH, IT DEFINITELY, YOU KNOW
HITS HARD AS FAR AS THAT'S
CONCERNED AND YOU KNOW WHEN I
SAW THAT NEWS BREAK YESTERDAY
AND YEAH, IT MAKES YOU PERK
UP IN YOUR SEAT AND READ INTO
IT AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS SO
IT DEFINITELY GIVES IT A MORE
REAL SENSE AFTER YESTERDAY
AND I DON'T KNOW MIKE I MEAN,
WHAT WAS YOUR OVERALL
THOUGHTS ON THE DAY JUST ALL
I THINK WAS A HORRIBLE DAY
FOR DESEAN WADS. YOU THINK I
THINK WAS HORRIBLE. YEAH, I
THINK IT'S HORRIBLE. I THINK
IT WAS HORRIBLE IN EVERY
RESPECT. THE PRESS CONFERENCE
WAS HORRIBLE FOR DESHAUN
WATSON THE RESPONSE BY RUSTY
HARDENED HIS LAWYER, WHICH
WE'LL DISCUSS LATER IN THE
PROGRAM WAS HORRIBLE AND IT
WAS JUST A HUGE JUST HUGE
REGRETTABLE MISTAKE, AND I
THINK THAT THAT IT IT'S ALL
DIFFERENT NOW AND IT'S ALL
CHANGED FOR ME NOW AND AS
I'LL EXPLAIN LATER
HER IN THE PROGRAM. I THINK
THE LEAGUE HAS NO CHOICE, BUT
TO PUT THEM ON THE
COMMISSIONER EXEMPT LIST NOW.
NOT LATER NOT JUST WELL.
THERE'S NO FOOTBALL SEASON.
NOW, THERE'S NO FOOTBALL
ACTIVITIES WILL JUST IGNORE
IT. I THINK IT'S TOO
SIGNIFICANT NOW TO IGNORE IT.
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S
RESONATING ENOUGH WITH THE
AVERAGE FOOTBALL FAN THAT I
THINK REASONABLE PEOPLE ARE
WONDERING WHY DOES THE NFL
HAVE ITS HEAD IN THE SAND ON
THIS? IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
ISSUE A PERIODIC STATEMENT
WILL SHARE THEIR STATEMENT
LATER, BUT I JUST THINK IT
WAS A BAD DAY FOR DESHAUN
AND WHATEVER WILL HAPPEN WILL
HAPPEN IF HE'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE THINGS HE'S ACCUSED
OF DOING HE DESERVES TO FACE
A RECKONING. I'VE ARGUED OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS THE
BEST WAY TO DO IT IS
VOLUNTARILY FACE YOUR
RECKONING WORK THESE CLAIMS
OUT WORK THEM OUT TO
EVERYONE'S SATISFACTION
RESOLVE THIS MATTER AS
QUICKLY AS YOU CAN WHILE ALSO
UNDERSTANDING WHAT YOU DID
AND PROVIDING SOME FORM OF
JUSTICE TO THOSE WHO HAVE
AT STORIES IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE EASY TO DO. OTHERWISE,
THIS THING IS GOING TO LINGER
AND HOVER FOR A YEAR OR TWO
OR LONGER IF HE DIGS IN AND
FIGHTS AND MY CONCERN IS THAT
HE'S GOING TO DIG IN AND
FIGHT WHEN MAYBE HE SHOULDN'T
YEAH, AND AGAIN, WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT MORE. AND AND THIS
IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I
FEEL THIS WAY WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO NOW. WE'RE GOING
TO PLAY THE STATEMENT FROM
YESTERDAY OF ASHLEY. SO LEAST
IT'S OVER FIVE MINUTES LONG,
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
DON'T CHANGE THE CHANNEL IF
YOU WANT TO UNDERSTAND THIS
CASE.
AND IF YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
SAME HUMAN REACTION THAT
PEOPLE HAD YESTERDAY WHEN
THEY SAW AND HEARD THE WORDS
FROM ASHLEY SOLIS YOU OWE IT
TO YOURSELF TO JUST HEAR HER
OUT TO JOHN WATSON'S GOT THE
ABILITY TO BE HEARD OUT
WHENEVER HE WANTS HE CAN HE
CAN HAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE
ANYTIME. HE WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT THIS SHE CHOSE TO DO SO
YESTERDAY. SHE'S THE FIRST OF
THE 22 PLAINTIFFS WHO CAME
FORWARD WITH NAME FACE AND
VOICE AND HERE SHE IS FROM
YESTERDAY AT THE TONY BOTH BE
PRESS CONFERENCES ASHLEY. SO
LEAST THE FIRST PERSON WHO
SUED DESHAUN WATSON THREE
WEEKS AGO,
MY NAME IS ASHLEY SOLIS.
I HOPE EVERY WOMAN A MAN OUT
THERE WHO IS A SURVIVOR.
HERE'S MY STORY AND I HOPE MY
STORY GIVE HIM COURAGE TO
SPEAK OUT.
IT HAS TAKEN ME A LONG TIME
TO GET TO THIS POINT THE COME
OUT PUBLICLY AND SPEAK MY
TRUTH.
I KNOW A LOT OF YOU ARE
PROBABLY WONDERING WHO I WAS
OR IF I EVEN EXISTED I WAS
I'M NOT AFRAID ANYMORE.
DOING THIS
I'M HERE TO TAKE PAT. TAKE
BACK THE POWER AND TAKE BACK
CONTROL.
I AM A SURVIVOR OF ASSAULT
AND HARASSMENT DESHAUN WATSON
IS MY FUTURE AND MY HARVESTER.
DESHAUN WATSON ASSAULTED AND
HARASSED ME ON MARCH 30TH
2020 IN MY OWN HOME DOING
WHAT I LOVE MOST.
MASSAGE THERAPY
I AM A LICENSED MASSAGE
THERAPIST NOW THAT THAT
PROFESSION THAT I LOVE SO
MUCH HAS BEEN FOREVER TAINTED.
I'M DEEPLY SADDENED BUT NOT
SURPRISED TO SEE SO MUCH
VICTIM BLAMING IN THE PRESS
AND BY ONLINE COMMENTERS AND
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA
WHAT I'M GOING THROUGH OR
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME NO IDEA.
THIS INCIDENT HAS IMPACTED ME
IN MANY WAYS. AND THOSE WAYS
ARE HARD TO DESCRIBE.
I FEEL A RANGE OF EMOTIONS
GUILT EMBARRASSMENT SHAME.
COURAGE ANGER SADNESS AND
NUMBNESS
SOME DAYS. I FEEL LIKE A HERO
OTHER DAYS. I FEEL LIKE A
I REPLAYED THE INCIDENT OVER
AND OVER IN MY HEAD AS IF I'M
TRYING TO WAKE UP FROM SOME
HORRIBLE NIGHTMARE ONLY THAT
NIGHTMARE IS REAL I BLAME
MYSELF AT TIMES WHICH IS
INSANE SOCIETY HAS GROOM
WOMEN TO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
THEIR FAULT WHEN THEY
HARASSED OR ASSAULTED AS IF
SOMEHOW WE ASK FOR IT OR IS
IT SOMEHOW WE COULD HAVE
PREVENTED IT? I CAN NO LONGER
PRACTICE THE PROFESSION AND I
LOVE THE MOST WITHOUT SHAKING
MY HANDSHAKE WHENEVER I
PLEASE DON'T WANT TO CLEAN
AND I'VE HAD TO CUT SESSION
IF YOU ONLY KNEW HOW
HEARTBREAKING THAT IT'S ME, I
GOT INTO MASSAGE THERAPY TO
HEAL PEOPLE.
TO HEAL THEIR MINDS AND BODIES
TO BRING PEACE OF THEIR SOULS.
DESHAUN WATSON HAS ROBBED ME
HE TOOK THAT AWAY FROM ME. HE
THINKS IT A PROFESSION AND
WHICH I TAKE ENORMOUS PRIDE.
FLASHES OF WATCHING SPACE
RUSH TO ME IN THE MOMENT
. I THINK OF HIS PENIS
TOUCHING ME WITH SENDS ME
INTO A TAILSPIN I SUFFER FROM
PANIC ATTACKS ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION. I'M IN COUNSELING
AS A RESULT OF THIS SEAN
I HOPE HE KNOWS HOW MUCH PAIN
HE'S INFLICTED ON ME
AND I HOPE HE KNOWS HOW MUCH
PAIN HE'S INFLICTED ON THESE
OTHER SURVIVORS.
MY FATHER WHO WAS ONCE A
DIE-HARD TEXTING SPAN CAN NO
LONGER MENTION HIS NAME
WITHOUT TURNING RED SEETHING
I THINK THAT THAT'S THE MOST
HEARTBREAKING ASPECT OF IT
ALL WE WERE ALL DECEIVED INTO
THINKING DESHAUN WATSON WAS A
GOOD GUY. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
WE KNOW THAT GOOD GUYS CAN DO
TERRIBLE THINGS. THIS
INCIDENT IS A PART OF ME,
BUT IT'S NOT ALL OF ME. I
WOULD NOT LET THE SEAN WATSON
TO FIND WHO I AM. I WOULD NOT
LET HIM WIN HE NEEDS TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS
ACTIONS. I WILL NOT LET HIM
TAKE MY POWER AWAY.
I'M STRONGER NOW, AND I KNOW
WHO I AM.
PEOPLE SAY THAT I'M DOING
THIS JUST FOR MONEY. THAT IS
I COME FORWARD NOW SO THAT
DESHAUN WATSON DOES NOT
ASSAULT ANOTHER WOMAN AND I
COME FORWARD NOW IN THE HOPES
THAT NO OTHER HUMAN BEING
WILL SOLVE ANOTHER IN THE
FUTURE. I WANT TO PREVENT
THIS TYPE OF CONDUCT. I COME
FORWARD NOW TO BRING CHANGE
IN OUR SOCIETY. I'M SEEKING
JUSTICE NOT JUST ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF, BUT FOR ALL SURVIVORS
I STAND WITH YOU ALL.
IS IT ABOUT HAVING MY VOICE
HEARD? THIS IS ABOUT HAVING
OTHER SURVIVORS VOICES HEARD
ANNETTE. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
SOLIS AND I AM A SURVIVOR
MEATY. THANK YOU.
YEAH, THAT WAS ACTUALLY
SOLIS YESTERDAY AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE HELD BY TONY BUZZ
BE THE FIRST PERSON TO COME
FORWARD NAME FACE AND VOICE
AND IT'S A POWERFUL FIVE
MINUTES AND IT DOES CHANGE
EVERYTHING BECAUSE IT GIVES
ANYONE WHO'S PAYING.
TENSION CHRIS SOMETHING
TANGIBLE SOMEONE THAT THEY
CAN RELATE TO SOMEONE THAT
THEY CAN RELATE TO SOMEONE
THAT THEY CAN SEE A SISTER A
NICE A SPOUSE A GIRLFRIEND A
COUSIN SOMEONE. THEY KNOW
IT'S IT'S JUST NOT JANE DOE
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT WONDER
WHETHER OR NOT RUSTY HARDENED
STRATEGY OF CONSTANTLY
PUSHING THIS ISSUE OF WHO ARE
THESE WOMEN? THEY'RE ALL JANE
DOE. THEY'RE ALL JANE DOE
SUGGESTING THEY DIDN'T EVEN
EXIST AT TIMES YOU READ
BETWEEN THE LINES. I WONDER
ENDED UP FUELING THE DESIRE
BY ASHLEY SO LEAST TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE SAW HER AND
HEARD HER AND REALIZE THERE
ARE REAL HUMAN BEINGS WHO ARE
MAKING THESE 22 CLAIMS
AGAINST DESHAUN WATSON. YEAH.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
CAN WATCH THAT AND NOT FEEL
COMPASSION FOR HER. YOU KNOW
THAT MEAN THE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE ON READING THE
STATEMENT ITSELF. YOU COULD
TELL HOW SHAKEN SHE IS BY THE
JUBILATION AND THAT SHE'S GOT
TO GO BACK THERE IN HER MIND
TO THAT MOMENT. AND ONCE
AGAIN, YOU KNOW THAT THAT TO
ME IS WHERE IT FOR ALL THOSE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO WERE
DOUBTING THIS RIGHT? AND
GOING OH 22 PEOPLE AND THEY
NEVER WENT TO THE COPS AND DO
THOSE THINGS WHEN YOU SEE
THAT THAT ANSWERS A LOT OF
THAT FROM LEAST FOR ME
BECAUSE IT'S JUST AS A WOMAN
AND MEN CAN UNDERSTAND THIS
BECAUSE WE'RE A DIFFERENT
ANIMAL THAN WOMEN ALTOGETHER.
TOGETHER IT'S JUST WERE A
DIFFERENT SPECIES BUT AS A
WOMAN TO GO TO THE COPS AND
MAKE SOMETHING LIKE THAT
PUBLIC. IT'S NOT EASY. IT'S
NOT EASY JUST TO DO THAT AND
NOW BRING ATTENTION ON THAT
AND NOW MY FAMILY KNOWS MY
PERSONAL LIFE AND I GOT TO
LOOK AT MY DAD. WHO KNOWS
THESE THINGS WENT ON AND NOW
THEY'RE IN HIS HEAD AND I GOT
TO LOOK AT MY DAD AND I'M
THINKING THAT HE'S THINKING
THAT YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHERE
YOU KNOW, JUST IT GIVES IT'S
A I HAVE A LOT OF
PASSION FOR HER THAT WAS I
WAS BRAVE ON HER PART, AND
I WOULD HOPE FOR THE PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO RIGHT NOW THINK
THAT THIS IS YOU KNOW, AND
AGAIN I WAS ONE OF THOSE ON
THE FENCE. THIS IS FISHY.
THIS IS WEIRD, BUT WE ARE AT
22 PEOPLE NOW 22 PEOPLE AND
THEN 18 OTHERS WHO CAME OUT
AND YOU KNOW AGAIN DEFENDED
HIM, BUT THAT'S STILL WEIRD
THAT STILL IT'S 40 MASSEUSES.
IT'S UNHEARD OF IN THE
HISTORY OF FOOTBALL. NOBODY
SO I DON'T KNOW BUT YES,
THAT'S THAT'S A TOUGH MOMENT
FOR DESHAUN WATSON AND HIS
TEAM BECAUSE I WOULD THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
WATCH THAT AND REALIZE THAT
LIKE LISTEN, SHE'S NOT THAT
GREAT OF AN ACTOR TO BE DOING
THAT THAT WAS REAL YOU COULD
TELL THERE WAS SOMETHING VERY
REAL AND TANGIBLE ABOUT IT.
AND YEAH, I THINK IT PUTS
WATSON AND HIS CAMP IN A VERY
VERY TOUGH POSITION AS WE GO
FORWARD HERE. WE'RE GOING TO
PIVOT BACK TO THE POINT OF
THE 18 MASSAGE THERAPIST WHO
SPOKE OUT IN SUPPORT
LAST WEEK OF DESHAWN.
WATSON BECAUSE
THAT ALSO IS BACKFIRING
FINALLY. I KNOW
TO LAUREN BAXLEY WHO WAS NOT
PRESENT YESTERDAY, BUT SHE
HAS DISCLOSED HER IDENTITY.
SHE IS ONE OF THE OTHERS WHO
HAVE COME FORWARD NOW, BUT
NOT FACE AND VOICE NAME SO FAR
WROTE A LETTER TO DESHAUN
WATSON AT THE RECOMMENDATION
OF HER COUNSELOR AS A WAY TO
PROCESS AND HE'LL ONE OF THE
AND HEAL ONE OF THE LAWYERS
FROM TONY BUSBY'S FIRM READ
THE
THE LETTER YESTERDAY DURING
THE PRESS CONFERENCE AND IT
WAS SIMILAR IN MANY RESPECTS
TO THE THINGS THAT ASHLEE
SOLIS SAID EVERY BOUNDARY
FROM PROFESSIONAL THERAPEUTIC
TO SEXUAL AND DEGRADING YOU
CROSSED IS WHAT LAUREN BAXLEY
SAID SEAN WATSON IN THIS
LETTER. YOU'RE NOTHING MORE
THAN A PREDATOR WITH POWER.
YOU'RE A GOOD GUY. PERSONA IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A
METICULOUSLY DESIGNED FACADE
TO KEEP YOUR VICTIMS SILENT
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE SO
FAR NOW TONY BUZZ
ALSO SPOKE CHRIS ABOUT THE
PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR THE
THINGS HE DID THESE ARE
ALLEGATIONS. AND AS I SAID,
DESHAUN WATSON IS FREE TO
FILL THE VACUUM OF SILENCE ON
HIS SIDE ANYTIME. HE WANTS
UNDERSTANDING ANYTHING. HE
SAYS CAN AND WILL BE USED
AGAINST HIM IN CIVIL COURT
POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL COURT,
BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE TO REMAIN
SILENT IN THE FACE OF THIS.
HERE'S WHAT BUSBY SAID
YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS PATTERN
IN WHICH HE ALLEGES WATSON
EACH OF THE CASES MAKES A
DESCRIBING OR DESCRIBES A
STRIKINGLY SIMILAR PATTERN OF
WATSON REACHES OUT TO WOMEN
ON SOCIAL MEDIA PARTICULARLY
INSTAGRAM
HE ASKED FOR A MASSAGE EVEN
THOUGH SOME OF THESE WOMEN
WERE NOT MASSAGE THERAPIST
AND WE'RE DOING OTHER TYPES
OF WORK, BUT HE SPECIFICALLY
ASKED FOR A MASSAGE AND WHEN
THEY SAY I DON'T DO MASSAGES
HE HAS SOMEWHAT CAN YOU DO A
MASSAGE?
WATCHING ARRANGES THE
APPOINTMENT ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AGAIN, PARTICULARLY INSTAGRAM.
HE REPEATEDLY INSISTS THAT
THE WOMAN BE ALONE CITING
PRIVACY CONCERNS.
AND IN SOME CASES EVEN
DICTATES THAT WHAT HE WANTS
THE PARTICULAR WOMAN TO WEAR
IN SOME CASES. HE TAKES
PICTURES OF THE PARTICULAR
WOMAN FROM INSTAGRAM AND
SENDS IT TO HER AND SAYS
WHERE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
BECAUSE IT'S HOT TODAY OR
IT'S HOT IN HOUSTON.
HE INSISTS REPEATEDLY EVEN
WHEN TOLD THAT IT'S NOT
NORMAL TO USE A TOWEL FOR
COVER IN MOST CASES. HE
INSISTS ON BRINGING HIS OWN
TOWEL.
WITH A TOWEL IS INSTEAD IS A
IN SOME CASES. HE ASKED THE
WOMAN TO SIGN A NONDISCLOSURE
AND IN SOME CASES, HE ASKED
THE WOMAN TO SIGN THE
AFTER THE SESSION.
YOU KNOW OTHER THINGS THAT
TONY BUSBY SAID CHRIS BEYOND
THAT PATTERN IN WHICH HE
ALLEGES WATSON ENGAGED THERE
WERE TIMES WHERE HE GOT
REFERRALS TO MASSAGE
THERAPIST FROM MEMBERS OF THE
TEXANS ORGANIZATION. THEY
WERE TIMES HE BORROWED TABLES
FROM THE TEXANS FOR THESE
MASSAGE SESSIONS AND EVEN
THOUGH HE WAS CAREFUL NOT TO
SAY HE'S NOT ACCUSING THE
TEXANS OF ANYTHING. YEAH ONE
POINT. HE SAID AT SOME POINT
YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION AS
UP. WE HAVE MASSAGE THERAPIST
ON STAFF IF YOU ARE ENGAGING
THESE PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS FOR
SEPARATE SESSIONS ON SUCH A
FREQUENT BASIS. WHAT'S REALLY
GOING ON HERE AND I SUSPECT
HE'LL EXPLORE THAT AS PART OF
HIS DUTY TO HIS CLIENTS
BECAUSE IF THERE IS AN
ARGUMENT TO BE MADE
EVENTUALLY IN GOOD FAITH WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE RELEVANT
TEXAS LAWS THAT THERE WAS
SOME NEGLIGENCE BY THE TEXANS
THAT THEY KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE
CONDUCT AND THEY DIDN'T
SHIELD THESE INDIVIDUALS FROM
IT. IN FACT, THEY REFERRED
HIM TO THEM THAT THAT THAT
BECOMES A POTENTIAL LEGAL
QUANDARY FOR THE HOUSTON
TEXANS AND IT'S CLEAR THAT
BUSBY IS GOING TO INVESTIGATE
WHETHER IT GOES ANYWHERE IS A
DIFFERENT ISSUE, BUT IT'S
CLEAR FROM WHAT HE SAID
YESTERDAY IS GOING TO INVEST
WELL AND AND THEN THE THING
THAT JUMPS OUT TO ME ABOUT
MORE THAN ANY OF THAT AND
THAT WILL DISPEL THE AGAIN.
I'M GOING TO STATE THIS I WAS
ONE AND THAT CAMP RIGHT? THIS
IS A LITTLE FISHY. I DON'T
KNOW. IT JUST SEEMS WEIRD
DESERT A CONNECTION BETWEEN
HIM AND KALMYK DARE.
AND THE HOUSTON TEXANS, IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT'S WHERE
THEY'VE GOTTEN TOGETHER AND
CONSPIRED AND KNEW THIS WAS
GOING ON AND NOW, YOU KNOW
HAVE DONE THIS TO DESHAUN
WATSON WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
YESTERDAY THAT THAT ENDS THAT
THAT'S AT LEAST WHAT IT DID
FOR ME WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GO.
OH, I MEAN IF HE ATTACKS THE
HOUSTON TEXANS AND THEN
STARTS TO BRING LITIGATION
UPON THEM THEN YA KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT IN
CAHOOTS TOGETHER IN SOME
GRAND CONSPIRACY TO BRING
DESHAUN WATSON DOWN BECAUSE
HE'S A POWER PLAYER IN
HOUSTON AND WANTED OUT OF THE
HOUSTON TEXANS ORGANIZATION.
I THINK THAT'S THE
THE BIGGEST TELL TO ME WITH
THAT BECAUSE I THINK MIKEY I
MEAN YOU LOOK ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THAT'S THAT'S THE BIG THING
RIGHT NOW AND SOCIAL MEDIA IS
PEOPLE QUESTIONING THE
REALNESS OF THIS. IS THERE A
CONSPIRACY BEHIND IT. IT'S SO
ODD THAT HE WAS ABOUT TO BE
TRADED AND THEN THIS CAME OUT
AND ALL OF THAT AND I'M JUST
SAYING THESE THINGS TO MAYBE
HELP SOME OF THOSE WHO WERE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND THEY'RE
WATCHING TO GO WAIT KNOW THAT
THAT DOESN'T ADD UP WE GOT TO
AND YOUR REACTION CHRIS AND
THEIR REACTION IS NOT
UNREASONABLE BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THIS ALL PLAYED OUT.
RIGHT RIGHT. TONY BUSBEE WAS
THE ONE WHO WAS FRONT AND
CENTER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SUGGESTED BASED UPON THE WAY
HE WAS CONDUCTING HIMSELF THE
THINGS HE WAS SAYING REMEMBER
THE FIRST PRESS CONFERENCE
WHEN HE ON HIS OWN RAISES
THESE SILLY RUMORS ABOUT SOME
SORT OF CONNECTION WITH THE
TEXANS AND HE PRETENDS NOT TO
KNOW COW MCNAIR'S FIRST NAME.
HOW DOES HE NOT KNOW COW
MCNAIR'S FIRST NAME LITTLE
THINGS LIKE THAT FED INTO THE
IDEA THAT SOMETHING WAS FISHY
AND IT IT NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ABOUT THE LAWYERS. IT
NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABOUT
TONY BUSBY. IT SHOULD HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS AND I COULDN'T
HELP BUT WONDER YESTERDAY
WHETHER HE JUST HAS MANAGED
TO EXECUTE SOME SORT OF
ELABORATE ROPE-A-DOPE ON
DESHAUN WATSON AND RUSTY
HARDENED TO SET UP WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY. I DON'T
KNOW THAT ANY LAWYER IS SMART
ENOUGH TO PULL OFF WHAT HAS
AND DELIBERATELY, BUT HE
DO YOU MEAN BY ROPE A DOPE?
LIKE WHY? WHAT DID HE DO TO
THIS IT? YEAH THAT JUST THE
WAY HE WAS HANDLING THINGS
THE WAY HE WAS CONDUCTING
HIMSELF THE WAY HE WAS MAKING
IT LOOK LIKE HE WAS IN IT FOR
PUBLICITY. HE WAS PLANTING
THESE SEEDS THAT WERE CAUSING
PEOPLE TO REASONABLY SAY
SOMETHING'S NOT RIGHT HERE.
SOMETHING'S FISHY. I HAVE
QUESTIONS. I HAVE DOUBTS
RIGHT AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN ASHLEY SOLIS SHOWS UP
YESTERDAY, AND ANYONE WHO
HAD DOUBTS HIS WHOLE MY GOD.
YEAH, IT'S GOT A LOT MORE
IMPACT IF IT HAPPENS THAT WAY
IF HE'S MANAGED TO CREATE
DOUBT IN HIS OWN CAUSE FOR
THREE WEEKS AND THEN YOU
BRING OUT VICTIM NUMBER ONE
WHO TELLS A COMPELLING STORY
AT A TIME WHEN PEOPLE LIKE
YOU PEOPLE LIKE ME OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE JUST BEEN LIKE
SOMETHING'S NOT RIGHT.
SOMETHING DOESN'T ADD UP
RIGHT? I THINK IT'S A LOT
MORE IMPACTFUL. THAT'S WHERE
I'M SAYING. IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF ROPE. I GOT YOU. I GOT YOU
WHERE HE DREW US IN HE DREW
WATSON IN HE DREW HARDENED IN
ALL THINKING.
AND IT'S A LITTLE WOBBLY AND
THEN AND THEN HE DELIVERS THE
KNOCKOUT PUNCH AND TRUST ME.
NOTHING HAPPENS ACCIDENTALLY
EVEN THOUGH WE WITNESSED
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS A VERY
REAL HUMAN MOMENT YESTERDAY
FROM ASHLEY SOLIS. YEAH. THIS
IS ALL BEING ORCHESTRATED AND
STRATEGIZE BY THE LAWYER IN
AN EFFORT TO BEST REPRESENT
HER AND THE REST OF THE
CLIENTS AND IT WORKED IT
WORKED FOR AS MUCH AS IT MAY
NOT HAVE WORKED THE FIRST
THREE WEEKS. IT WORKED
YESTERDAY. SO THAT'S MY POINT.
AND AND IF IT WAS DELIBERATE
IT'S GENIUS
BECAUSE
THERE WERE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE.
SWIRLING AND I THINK ANYONE
WHO PAID ATTENTION TO
YESTERDAY HAVE BEEN RESOLVED.
THEY SHOULD BE I MEAN, I
AGREE WITH YOU THERE, BUT BUT
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
RESOLVED BECAUSE OF THE OTHER
ASPECT OF THE YOU KNOW, AND I
DON'T WANT TO JUMP THE GUN
HERE ON OUR PROGRAM. BUT I
MEAN, IT'S JUST COMING UP
KIND OF ORGANICALLY HERE OF
THE $100,000 RIGHT QUICK
. THE THE THE CIVIL. HEY,
WE'LL KEEP THIS OUT OF A YOU
KNOW, THE COURTROOM AND ALL
THAT IF YOU PAY, YOU KNOW
SOLIS,
ASPECT THAT I KNOW THIS
LOOKING AT SOCIAL MEDIA THAT
JUMPS OUT TO ME. NOW. THERE'S
THAT CAMP THERE. THAT'S JUST
GOES. WELL THEY'RE BACK INTO
THE WELL, YOU SEE THAT IT IS
ABOUT THE MONEY WHICH AGAIN
IS WRONG. I DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT. BUT THERE'S TOO MANY
PEOPLE WHO JUST TAKE LITTLE
SNIPPETS AND SNIPPETS AND
SNIPPETS AND THEY LOSE THE
CONTEXT OF THE SITUATION OR A
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THE
SITUATION ALTOGETHER AND
THEY'RE JUST GOING AT IT AT A
VERY BASE FACE LEVEL THAT WAY
AND THAT'S THE OTHER THING I
GUESS THAT NOW
BUSBY'S GOING TO HAVE TO
TO DEAL WITH THE TO TO A
DEGREE PART OF THE PROBLEM.
THAT PEOPLE ARE BEHAVING THE
WAY THAT WE BEHAVE ON ALL
MATTERS OF POLITICS OR STRONG
EVERYTHING'S OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR
POSITION THAT WE ESTABLISH
WHY THAT NO FACTS. I DON'T
KNOW BUT WE ESTABLISH OUR
POSITION AND THEN EVERY
ADDITIONAL FACT IS RUN
THROUGH OUR POSITION AND
WARPED INTO A WAY THAT
ARE HAVING THE THE COURAGE OR
RIGHT THE LACK SELF SCOUTS I
SELLING THIS. YEAH TO TAKE A
STEP BACK AND SAY MAYBE MY
FIRST REACTION RIGHT WRONG,
RIGHT MAYBE CIRCUMSTANCES
HAVE CHANGED. MAYBE I SHOULD
HAVE KEPT AN OPEN MIND AND I
THINK THAT THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME WHO STILL CONTINUE TO
TO LISTEN TO THE ARGUMENT
AND PROCESS THIS NOTION THAT
IT'S JUST A MONEY GRAB
BECAUSE IT STARTED AS AN
ATTEMPT TO RESOLVE THE CASE
WITHOUT LITIGATION AND THAT
WAS THE GIST CHRIS. YEAH OF
THE RUSTY HARDENED STATEMENT
YESTERDAY, RIGHT? IT WAS A
LONG STATEMENT. IT WAS WAY
TOO LONG GENERAL PR ADVICE TO
ANY LAWYERS OR ANYONE ELSE
OUT THERE DOWN IF YOUR
STATEMENT LOOKS LONG, IT'S
LONG. YEAH, AND AND LOOK AT
THAT. LOOK AT THAT YOU NEED,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE CAN'T KEEP
THEIR ATTENTION FOR FOUR
SECONDS. IT'S TOO LONG. IF
YOU CAN'T MAKE YOUR POINT
QUICKLY. MAYBE IT'S A POINT
THAT SHOULDN'T BE MADE BUT
WHAT HARDEN IS TRYING TO SAY
I THINK HIS FIRST MISTAKE
HAPPENS. YEAH, HE'S TRYING TO
PAINT ASHLEY SOLIS AS A LIAR
WHEN SHE SAYS THAT IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT THE MONEY. PEOPLE
I'M JUST DOING THIS FOR MONEY
DOING THIS JUST FOR MONEY
THAT WAS ONE OF HER QUOTES
AND THEY HIGHLIGHT IN THE
FIRST PARAGRAPH OF THE
STATEMENT, AND SHE SAYS THAT
PARAGRAPH OF THE STATEMENT
AND SHE SAYS THAT IS FALSE.
SO HE TAKES AIM AT THAT RIGHT
BY REWINDING TO FEBRUARY WHEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE VERY
DIFFERENT AND DISCLOSING
DETAILS THAT SUPPOSEDLY OR
CONFIDENTIAL BETWEEN THE
LAWYERS WHEN THESE THINGS
HERE'S WHAT I WANT PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE HARD NEWS
IS A PEJORATIVE TERM HUSH
MONEY. THEY SOUGHT HUSH MONEY.
LOOK THIS IS THE WAY THE
LEGAL SYSTEM WORKS. I WAS IN
IT FOR 18 YEARS. YEAH BOTH
FIND THIS FILE, SO DON'T GET
THIS. YEAH, AND THIS HAPPENS
VERY VERY FREQUENTLY. NOW,
SOMETIMES YOU DECIDE IT'S NOT
WORTH EVEN TRYING OR THERE'S
AN ELEMENT OF SURPRISE THAT
YOU WANT TO PRESERVE BY SUING
FIRST, AND THEN HAVING
SETTLEMENT DISCUSSIONS LATER,
YOU'RE DEALING
WITH A HIGH-PROFILE PERSON WHO
DOES NOT WANT OR SHOULDN'T
WANT CONTROVERSIES LIKE THIS
ATTACHED TO HIS OR HER NAME
THERE IS VALUE IN APPROACHING
THE PERSON AHEAD OF TIME AND
SAYING HERE IS MY GRIEVANCE.
THIS IS MY CONCERN. THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED AND I AM GIVING
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE
THE CASE RESOLVED THE
GRIEVANCE RESOLVE THE CLAIM
NOW.
BEFORE WE GO TO COURT AND
PEOPLE THINK THAT'S EXTORTION.
IT'S NOT THIS IS THE WAY THE
SAUSAGE GETS MADE
LEGITIMATELY AND LEGALLY IN
THE LEGAL PROFESSION EVERY
SINGLE DAY. IT'S ENCOURAGED.
SOMETIMES IT'S WELL WHAT'S
ALWAYS ENCOURAGED TO SETTLE?
YEAH, AND YOU'RE AT SOME
POINT IN ALMOST EVERY
JURISDICTION IN THE UNITED
STATES AFTER YOU FILE THE
LAWSUIT THE JUDGE WILL
REQUIRE YOU TO TRY TO SETTLE
THE CASE BUT IN A CASE LIKE
THIS YOU GO TO THE DEFENDANT
AHEAD OF TIME YOU HAVE THE
CONVERSATION
WHERE IS IT AND RUSTY
HARDENED DISCLOSED ALL OF THE
EMAILS THE BACK AND FORTH AND
IT'S AMAZING TO ME SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WERE
DISCLOSED BECAUSE AT ONE
POINT AND AND THIS IS WHERE
WERE YOU KNOW, THE $100,000
DEMAND AND AND FOLKS LOOK, I
DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
LEGAL CLIMATE HOUSTON, BUT
FOR THE ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE HERE AND ALL
THINGS CONSIDERED A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AS AN OPENER
AS AN OPEN TO SEE THAT'S THE
OTHER THING THAT PEOPLE ARE
LOSING SIGHT OF YES.
YES, THAT'S AN OPENER WHEN
YOU DEMAND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PRE LAWSUIT IN THE
FIRST NUMBER THAT YOU PUT ON
THE TABLE WHEN NEGOTIATING
WITH THE LAWYER WHO
REPRESENTS THE PERSON AGAINST
WHOM THE CLAIM IS MADE THAT
MEANS YOU'RE GOING TO MOVE
SOUTH OF A HUNDRED. YOU DON'T
START AT A HUNDRED AND SAY
IT'S A HUNDRED OR NOTHING. I
WAS SURPRISED BY THE NUMBER
TWO. I THOUGHT IT WAS LOW.
OKAY, SO I'M GOOD GOD THESE
ARE YOU SO SO YEAH, SO THE
WAY IT'S SUPPOSED TO WORK IS
YOU STARTED A HUNDRED.
AND THEN THERE'S A RESPONSE
BY THE DEFENDANT AND THEN
THERE'S A MOVEMENT BUT IT'S A
VERY AND IT'S AMAZING TO ME
AND I REMEMBER BEING
SURPRISED BY THIS BECAUSE YOU
GO TO LAW SCHOOL AND YOU
EMERGE FROM THE PROCESS AND
YOU THINK THINGS ARE A
CERTAIN WAY AND IT'S ALL VERY
IDEALISTIC AND EVERYTHING IS
HANDLED AND JUSTICE IS BLIND
AND AND THEN YOU REALIZE THAT
THE END OF THE DAY A LOT OF
THIS PROCESS IS NO DIFFERENT
THAN HAGGLING OVER HOW MUCH
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY FOR A
POUND OF COFFEE IN A
MARKETPLACE AND THAT'S WHAT
IT COMES DOWN TO THAT'S HOW
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS ARE RESOLVED
TO LAWYERS GOING BACK AND
FORTH.
EARTH UNTIL THEY REACH A
MIDDLE GROUND AND WHAT
HAPPENED HERE WASN'T I THINK
BASED ON MY OWN EXPERIENCE IF
YOU OPEN WITH A HUNDRED
YOU'RE WILLING TO SETTLE
BETWEEN 50 AND 75. THAT'S THE
SIGNAL THAT YOU'RE SENDING
AND AND IN HINDSIGHT DESHAUN
WATSON. WHAT IF I'LL HAVE
TO FIFTY TO SEVENTY-FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO AVOID
THIS SOLD, YOU KNOW NOW I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OTHER
CLAIMS WOULD HAVE BEEN MADE.
YEAH, BUT I THINK PART OF
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IS AT SOME
POINT ALONG THE WAY THEY
PISSED OFF TONY BUSBY AND IT
MOTIVATED HIM TO DIG.
LITTLE BIT MORE AND DIG A
LITTLE BIT MORE MAYBE ALL
THIS STUFF WOULD HAVE
INEVITABLY COME OUT AT SOME
POINT, RIGHT BUT IT MOTIVATED
BUSBY TO SAY WELL, I'LL
LISTEN THEY AND HE SAYS IN
ONE OF HIS EMAILS THAT YOU
NEED TO LOOK INTO WHO YOU'RE
DEALING WITH AND HE DUG AND
DUG AND WE DUG BUT BUT THE
POINT IS THAT THE LAWYER WHO
WAS REPRESENTING DESHAUN
WATSON IS INTEREST AT THE
TIME DECIDED NOT TO RESPOND
TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
BASICALLY SAID IN A SOMEWHAT
CONDESCENDING WAY. WELL, WE
NEED MORE FACTS ARE WE NEED A
DIFFERENT NUMBER SEE THAT
VIOLATES THE ETIQUETTE
THERE'S AN ETIQUETTE THERE.
TORI I DID, YOU KNOW, I
DOUBLE DOG DARE YOU A TRIPLE
DOG DARE YOU THIS THEY SKIP
STEPS HE VIOLATED THE
ETIQUETTE BY NOT RESPONDING
JUST RESPOND WITH 10,000 IF
YOU THINK IT'S TOO MUCH AND
THEN SEE WHAT THEY DO, BUT
WHEN YOU GO BACK TO SOMEBODY
WHO'S MADE $100,000 DEMAND
AND SAY WE DON'T LIKE THAT
WILL MAKE ANOTHER THAT'S
NEVER GOING TO FLY AND IT
DIDN'T FLY HERE AND THE WORST
PART ABOUT ALL OF THIS AND I
STILL CAN'T BELIEVE CHRIS
THAT THEY PUT THESE EMAILS
VOLUNTARILY OUT INTO THE
PUBLIC CONSCIOUSNESS.
THE EMAIL FROM THE LAWYER
REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS OF
DESHAUN WATSON BEFORE RUSTY
HARDIN WAS INVOLVED RIGHT
SAID, WE DON'T BELIEVE THE
ALLEGED FACTS SHOW THAT THE
SEAN DID ANYTHING WRONG WITH
REGARDS TO MRS. SOLIS, BUT WE
ARE NEVERTHELESS HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
AROUND A REASONABLE
SETTLEMENT FIGURE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE HE CAN LEARN A LESSON
ABOUT HAVING PUT HIMSELF IN
THIS SITUATION. THAT'S WEIRD.
YEAH, AND
THEY
DISCLOSE THIS YESTERDAY RIGHT
AS PART OF A STATEMENT THAT
THEY THOUGHT WAS IN SOME WAY
GOING TO SERVE AS THE MAGICAL
SILVER BULLET THAT
EVISCERATED EVERYTHING ASHLEY
SOLIS SAID YESTERDAY CHRIS. I
CAN'T BELIEVE THIS AND
FRANKLY. WELL, IT'S TOO LATE
NOW FOR DESHAUN WATSON AND I
UNDERSTAND LOOK WHAT HAPPENS
IS YOU GET A BIG-NAME LAWYER
AND IT WILL RUSTY HARD. LET'S
GO GET RUSTY HARD. WELL, I
REMEMBER RUSTY HEART AND
THINGS UP FOR ROGER CLEMENS
IN MY OPINION. I DON'T WANT
TO GET
BYE RUSTY HARDENED, RIGHT?
I REMEMBER FALLING THE ROGER
CLEMENS CASE SAYING IS THIS
THE BEST ADVICE? YEAH THAT
ROGER CLEMENS COULD POSSIBLY
GET BECAUSE HE ENDED UP.
PROSECUTED FOR PERJURY I
BELIEVE. YES A HUNG JURY. I
MAY BE GETTING MY BASEBALL
STEROIDS LIARS WRONG HERE.
YOU COULD HAVE A WHOLE SET OF
TRADING CARDS JUST OF THOSE
GUYS, BUT BUT I JUST REMEMBER
THINKING RUSTY HARDEN IS NOT
THE THE THE EPITOME OF
LEGAL BRILLIANCE THAT WE ARE
BEING LED TO BELIEVE. HE IS
IN CONNECTION WITH THE
CLEMENS CASE. DEFINITELY IN
THIS CASE IN MY OPINION. GOT
TO MAKE SURE IT'S MY OPINION
AS SOMEONE WHO PRACTICED LAW
FOR 18 YEARS
THAT STATEMENT NEVER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ISSUED. WELL,
IT NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ISSUED. WELL, IT NEVER SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ISSUED. I'M WITH
YOU THERE BUSBY SEEMS LIKE
HE'S MORE WITH THE TIMES AND
KNOWS HOW TO WORK ALL THE
ANGLES AND HE'S YEAH, HE'S
HE'S JOHNNY LAWYER AND
ANNOYING AND BRASH AND IN
YOUR FACE AND CERTAINLY SEEMS
LIKE A JERK IN A LOT OF WAYS,
YOU KNOW, BUT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, HE'S EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE. THAT'S THE ONE
THING HE'S WON THE THE COURT
OF PUBLIC OPINION. LIKE YOU
SAID, I IT DOES ALMOST SEEMED
LIKE IT WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
A SETUP LIKE HEY, COME ON
AND THEN AS SOON AS THEY GOT
CLOSE BOOM, HERE'S A HAYMAKER.
OH, YEAH, RIGHT. I MEAN, YES
IT RUSTY HARDEN HAS NOT
AMAZED ME EITHER AT THIS
POINT AND I KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT WHAT HERE'S THE POINT
THAT I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR IF
WE ALWAYS AS LAWYERS AS
ADVERSARIES THE WHOLE IDEA IS
YOU TRY TO GET TO THE TRUTH
BY PITTING TWO SIDES AGAINST
EACH OTHER AND HAVING THEM
FIGHT IT OUT AND THE THOUGHT
IS THE TRUTH IS SOMEHOW GOING
TO POP UP IN THE PROCESS. SO
IT'S ALWAYS ADVERSARIAL
YOU'RE ALWAYS FIGHTING AND
AND IF YOU CAN DO THAT, IF
YOU CAN SUCCESSFULLY SHOW
THAT THE OTHER SIDE IS LYING.
DONE 98% OF YOUR JOB, BUT YOU
BETTER MAKE SURE THE THING
YOU'RE ATTACKING REALLY IS A
LIE. WHEN ASHLEY SOLIS SAYS
YESTERDAY PEOPLE SAY I'M
DOING THIS JUST FOR MONEY.
THAT IS FALSE.
SHE DIDN'T JUST LET ME KNOW I
JUST FOR MY SHE DIDN'T SAY
THAT IT'S FALSE THAT MONEY
ISN'T PART OF IT MONEY IS
PART OF IT. NOW MONEY IS PART
OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS THE
WAY THE PRE LITIGATION
SETTLEMENT WORKS. IT'S ALL
NORMAL SURE. THERE'S NOTHING
THAT THERE'S NOTHING AND AND
I THIS IS WHAT DISAPPOINTS ME
BECAUSE RUSTY HARDEN IS
WARPING THE WAY THE LEGAL
SYSTEM WORKS TRYING TO MAKE
PEOPLE THINK THAT ANY TIME
IT'S SOMEHOW EXTORTION. IT'S
UNTOWARD. IT'S HUSH MONEY.
IT'S NORMAL. YES. THIS IS
WHAT YOU DO, RIGHT? THERE'S
NOTHING THAT I SAW YESTERDAY
IN THAT STATEMENT OR IN THOSE
EMAILS THAT MADE ME THINK
THERE WAS ANYTHING IMPROPER
AND YES AT ONE POINT IN THE
PROCESS IF I CAN HAVE MY
CONCERNS RESOLVED QUIETLY
WITHOUT HAVING TO POTENTIALLY
TURN MY LIFE UPSIDE DOWN AND
SPEAK TO THE WORLD FOR FIVE
MINUTES WITH A STATEMENT IF I
CAN AVOID THAT THEN YEAH.
TAKE THIS PAYMENT BECAUSE
THAT'S MY FORM OF JUSTICE.
SURE SEE WHEN YOU AND SHE
CAN'T MASSAGE ANYMORE AND
SHE'S BEEN AFFECTED THAT WAY.
BUT YEAH, I MEAN IT'S
AFFECTED HER LIFE HER MONEY
EVERYTHING. SORRY, BUT BUT
HERE'S THE THING. I WANT
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND. YEAH
WHEN YOU'VE BEEN WRONGED BY
SOMEONE BY CONDUCT IT VERY
WELL MAY CROSS THE LINE INTO
CRIMINAL MISBEHAVIOR PART OF
THE VICTIMS POWER IS TO PICK
THE TYPE OF JUSTICE THAT HE
OR SHE IS GOING TO PURSUE.
YOU CAN GO TO THE COPS IF
HAVE TO YOU CAN FILE A CIVIL
LAWSUIT AND YOU HAVE THE FULL
EXTENT OF THE APPLICABLE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS TO
WAIT. AND ANYONE WHO SAYS,
WHY'D YOU WAIT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT'S WITHIN YOUR RIGHTS TO
WAIT. YEAH, YOU CAN YOU CAN
PURSUE JUSTICE IN A WIDE
VARIETY OF WAYS AND IT'S UP
TO THE VICTIM TO DECIDE HOW
TO DO IT AND ACTUALLY SOLIS
HAD CHOSEN A DIFFERENT WAY
AND WHEN - ON WATSON'S LAWYERS
ESSENTIALLY GAVE THEM THE
MIDDLE FINGER THEY CHOSE A
DIFFERENT WAY. YEAH, THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT BOTHERS ME ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE FOR THE SAME
REASONS, I BELIEVE TONY
BUSBEE WAS BEING DISINGENUOUS
EARLY ON RUSTY HARDENED IN
THIS STATEMENT. EVERYTHING
ABOUT IT TO ME IS WRONG. IT'S
DISINGENUOUS AND IT'S IN AN
IMPROPER.
AND OF THE WAY THE LEGAL
SYSTEM WORKS CHRIS AND THAT'S
WHAT BUGS ME THE MOST I AGREE
WILL AGAIN, IT GOES BACK TO
SOMETHING, YOU KNOW. YEAH,
WE'RE BEING, YOU KNOW, THE
SOCIETIES BEING MISLED TO
THINK THAT NORMAL PRACTICE
HERE IS NOT NORMAL JUST TO
DEFEND MY CLIENT TO MAKE IT
LOOK LIKE THIS WAS WRONG IN
THE COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION
AGAIN, THAT'S WHERE IT GOES
TO AND THAT'S FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE THAT JUST GOES ON
EVERYWHERE. ALL RIGHT. I KNOW
WE GOT TO GO TO A BREAK AND
IT BECAUSE I'M NOT ALL WE DO.
YEAH, BUT-BUT-BUT. I WANT I
WANT TO DO ONE MORE THING
BEFORE WE GO BECAUSE OKAY YOU
MENTIONED HOW
EFFECTIVE TONY BUSBY HAS BEEN
RIGHT AND I'VE BEEN CRITICAL
OF HIS WAYS IN THE PAST, BUT
THIS GOES BACK TO TRYING TO
WIN IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION. YOU THINK YOU HAVE A
SILVER BULLET IT ENDS UP
BEING A BOOMERANG. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PLAY
THIS THE 18 INDIVIDUALS LAST
WEEK WHO WENT ON THE RECORD
WITH THEIR NAMES WITH
STATEMENTS SUPPORTING DESHAUN
WATSON. THAT WAS A MOMENT
WHERE LIKE WOW. HEY, HERE. WE
ARE. WE GOT 22 PEOPLE. WE
DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE. WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THEY EXIST
RIGHT? WE GOT 18 HER
SUPPORTING DESHAUN WATSON
YESTERDAY, TONY.
BUSBY TOOK THAT SUPPOSED
SILVER BULLET AND TURNED IT
BACK AROUND ON DESHAUN WATSON.
LISTEN TO BUSBY FROM
YESTERDAY ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT WAS RELEASED SAID I'VE
BEEN PROVIDING MASSAGE
THERAPY TO DESEAN AND 2018
AND MASSAGE THEM AT LEAST 40
TIMES SINCE THEN.
I'VE NEVER HAD A SINGLE
UNCOMFORTABLE OR
INAPPROPRIATE EXPERIENCE WITH
DASHON. THAT WAS THE
STATEMENT THAT WAS RELEASED.
BUT LET ME READ TO YOU THE
DIRECT MESSAGE THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL SENT THAT WE NOW
I TOLD YOU I STOPPED WORKING
WITH HIM. YEAH, WHY BECAUSE I
WAS HEARING TOO MUCH STUFF
ABOUT HIM MESSING WITH OTHER
PEOPLE LIKE OTHER THERAPISTS
AND ESTHETICIANS. HE'S BEEN
DOING A LOT THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR MONTHS. I EVEN TOLD HIS
ASS. HE NEEDED BE CAREFUL
BECAUSE HIS NAME GETTING
AROUND. I JUST HOPE DON'T
NOBODY CALL ME TO QUESTION ME.
YEAH, THAT'S TWO DIFFERENT.
YEAH, SOMEBODY DID THEIR
HOMEWORK ON THE INDIVIDUAL.
YEAH WHOSE QUOTE WAS USED
LAST WEEK AND SOMEBODY ELSE
DIDN'T DO THEIR HOMEWORK AND
THERE'S 17 OTHERS SEE THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN SET UP
NOW IN THE BATTLEGROUND
ALWAYS SHIFTS AND CHANGES
WHEN YOU GET INTO LITIGATION
BECAUSE ONE SIDE WILL TRY TO
MAKE SOMETHING AN ISSUE. SO,
ALL RIGHT, LET'S EXPLORE IT.
YOU GOT THESE 18 PEOPLE. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S LET'S DO OUR
HOMEWORK. LET'S GET THIS A
LITTLE BIT. OH, YOU DIDN'T
IT TOO BAD FOR YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO VET IT AND LOOK WHAT
THEY
FOUND AND AND AND EVEN YOU
KNOW, AS WE SAID LAST WEEK
JUST BECAUSE 18 PEOPLE HAD
EXPERIENCES BUT SHOT TO SHOW
AND WATSON WHERE NOTHING
IMPROPER HAPPENED DOESN'T
MEAN THE OTHER 22 OR LYING.
YEAH POSSIBLE. EVERYONE'S
TELLING THE TRUTH, RIGHT? SO
BUT THIS THIS NOW THIS NOW
MAKES IT EVEN WORSE FOR
DESHAUN WATSON. WHEN ONE OF
THESE 18 PEOPLE WHO
SUPPOSEDLY WERE RUSHING TO
HIS DEFENSE LAST WEEK HAS
THESE DIRECT MESSAGES WHERE
SHE'S ACCORDING TO TONY BUSBY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT SHE WAS
AWARE.
ARE OF HIS REPUTATION TO THE
POINT WHERE SOMETHING NEEDED
TO BE SAID TO HIM BECAUSE
WORDS GETTING AROUND. IT'S
JUST IT'S IT ALL ADDS UP TO MY
BELIEF CHRISTIE YESTERDAY
WAS A VERY BAD DAY FOR
DESHAUN WATSON AND FOR HIS
LEGAL TEAM. YEAH. I'M WITH
YOU MIKE. I MEAN IT IS A
REALLY REALLY BAD DAY. I GUESS
THE NEXT AND IT SHOULD BE IF
HE'S GUILTY. IT SHOULD BE SEE
I TRY TO SEPARATE MY ANALYSIS
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION PRICE
YOU ALREADY OF THESE THINGS.
IT SHOULD BE A BAD DAY. NO,
HE SHOULD HAVE MANY MORE BAD
DAYS UNTIL HE HAS HIS
RECKONING AND MAKES THINGS
RIGHT AGREED MIKE. I MEAN
AGREED THERE'S NO DOUBT. SO I
MEAN THE NEXT THING HERE AND
I JUST SAID TO ME AS SOMEONE
HERE AGAIN, NOT A LAWYER
FOOTBALL FAN USED TO BE A
DESHAUN WATSON FAN NOT RIGHT
NOW I COULD TELL YOU THAT BUT
LIKE YOU SEE ASHLEY SOLIS THE
OTHER
MENTS BUSBY OUT THERE AT WHAT
POINT LIKE AGAIN IF RUSTY
HARDEN AND DESHAUN WATSON
WANT TO CLAIM THE
INNOCENT CARD AND YOU KNOW,
WHATEVER EXTORTION OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. I MEAN AT
WHAT POINT DOES DESHAUN
WATSON GOT TO SHOW HIS FACE
AND GET IN FRONT OF A CAMERA
AND WE GOT TO SEE HIS
EMOTIONS AND HOW HE ANSWERS
OR SAYS CERTAIN THINGS, YOU
KNOW, AND HOW HIS FACE LOOKS
BECAUSE ASHLEY SOLIS THE WAY
SHE SAID THAT IT HAD REAL
POWER TO IT AND I KIND OF
THINK AT THIS POINT TO THIS
FAR IN LIKE THE SEAN'S
DESHAUN WATSON SILENCE IS
KIND OF DEAFENING AT THIS
ANYTHING YOU SAY CAN AND WILL
BE USED AGAINST YOU IN A
COURT OF LAW AND THAT IS TRUE
IN CIVIL COURT IN CRIMINAL
COURT. AND THAT'S THE BALANCE
THAT THEY HAVE TO STRIKE
BECAUSE AS I SAID EARLIER,
HE'S FREE TO MAKE A STATEMENT
FOR FIVE MINUTES OR LONGER.
HE CAN CALL A PRESS
CONFERENCE. HE CAN DO AN
INTERVIEW. THERE ARE PLENTY
OF PLATFORMS WHERE HE CAN GET
A MESSAGE OUT OTHER THAN
SOMETHING THAT WAS WRITTEN ON
A NOTE SAP AND PASTED THE
SOCIAL MEDIA THREE WEEKS AGO
THATS THE ONLY THING WE'VE
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM DESHAUN
WATSON, RIGHT?
THE PROBLEM IS MOST LAWYERS
WHO LIKE TO PRESERVE THEIR
ABILITY TO WIN IN COURT
EVENTUALLY WOULD SAY DON'T DO
IT. DON'T DO IT. DON'T DO IT.
AND I THINK THAT'S PART OF
THE PROBLEM HERE. YOU GOT
RUSTY HARDENED WHO'S A
CRIMINAL LAWYER DEALING WITH
CIVIL CASES DEALING WITH
COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION. IT'S
YOU ALMOST THE RIGHT. I KNOW
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT RING. YOU
NEED YOU. YEAH, YOU YOU NEED
A PR SPECIALIST TO DEAL WITH
THE COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION
AGAINST CIVIL LAW SPECIALIST
DEAL WITH THE CIVIL CASES IN
LIST TO DEAL WITH THOSE AND
ULTIMATELY WHAT YOU NEEDED
WAS SOMEONE TO GET TO DESHAUN
WATSON EARLY ON SPEAK A HARD
TRUTH TO HIM GET HIM TO
REALIZE THE WAYS THE DOMINOES
COULD FALL THAT COULD DERAIL  '